THE NRA HAS GOT TO GO!
>> THE NRA IS THE WORST
ORGANIZATION IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> I AM A VERY MUCH ONE THAT IS
AGAINST HANDGUNS.
I KNOW IN MY URBAN ENVIRONMENT I
SEE LITTLE TO NO NEED FOR GUNS
AT ALL.
>> Tucker: YET.
JUST SOME RATIONAL DISCOURSE FOR
YOU.
WE DON'T NEED GUN SPREAD WILL OF
COURSE WE NEED GUNS.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO HAVE
GUNS.
THAT'S THE ATTITUDE.
THE LIBERALS ARE OBVIOUSLY
HIGHER BODY GUARDS.
THEY HAD THEMSELVES AWAY IN THE
SAFETY OF THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WHAT IF PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD TO
DO THAT?
WHAT WOULD GUN BENDS MEAN FOR
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN, SAY,
DETROIT, MICHIGAN?
THIS SHOW WENT TO DETROIT TO
INVESTIGATE THAT VERY QUESTION
AND HERE'S WHAT WE FOUND.
>> MY NAME IS ALAYNA AND I WAS
IN THE CITY OF DETROIT.
>> ALAYNA IS AN ARMS DETROIT
HER.
>> I KEEP MY GUN RIGHT HERE ON
MY LEG.
>> SHE CHOOSES TO CARRY A GUN TO
PROTECT YOURSELF AND IT HELPED
HER SURVIVE AN ARMED CARJACKING
AT A LIQUOR STORE ON THE WEST
SIDE PIT SHE WAS SHOT IN THE ARM
DURING AN ATTACK AND SHE DROVE
HERSELF TO THE HOSPITAL.
POLICE NEVER CAUGHT THE
ATTACKER.
BECAUSE THEY HAD AN AK AND I HAD
MY GLOCK AND IT WENT DOWN.
THEY SAW A PRETTY GIRL WITH PINK
LIPSTICK AND THEY JUST THOUGHT
THAT THEY COULD GET ME AND
SURPRISE, SURPRISE, I'M STACKED.
>> Tucker: STORIES LIKE HERS
ARE WHY SO MANY PEOPLE IN
DETROIT HAVE DECIDED TO TAKE
PERSONAL PROTECTION INTO THEIR
OWN HANDS.
YOU GO WHY DID YOU CARRY A
FIREARM?
>> BECAUSE I LIVE IN DETROIT.
>> WHY NOT CALL THE POLICE?
>> SOMETIMES IT TAKES A WHILE.
STILL IN DETROIT'S JUVENILE
POLICE JIM CRIED, AGREES >> IT
ONLY TAKES A MINUTE OR LESS FOR
VIOLENCE TO HAPPEN AND THEN
IT'S OVER.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHY CRAIG
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE RIGHT TO
CARRY.
>> IF THE CITIZEN IS ARMED, THEY
HAVE A BETTER OPPORTUNITY OF
STAYING ALIVE THEN IF THEY
WEREN'T.
>> Tucker: ISSUES GUN PERMITS
ANYONE IN DETROIT WHO TAKES THE
CLASS AND PASSES BACK ON TRACK.
ALAYNA TOOK HER CLASS WITH
DETROIT NATIVE, RICK.
IT DID A HIKE OUT.
SHOOT.
>> Tucker: THE GUN RIGHTS
GROUP NAMED LEGALLY ARMED IN
DETROIT, HAS HELPED THOUSANDS OF
WOMEN GET THEIR CARRY PERMITS.
>> WE HAVE A GROWING NUMBER OF
WOMEN HERE IN DETROIT WHO ARE
LEARNING MORE ABOUT FIREARMS AND
WHAT IT TAKES TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
>> DO YOU RECOMMEND THAT
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS GO OUT AND
GET THAT PERMIT?
>> IF THEY ARE LAW-ABIDING, THEY
GET THE TRAINING, ABSOLUTELY.
I PARTICULARLY SHOW INTEREST IN
FEMALE'S WHO AND SUPPORT SEAL
WEAPONS.
>> Tucker: NEARLY ONE IN EVERY
TEN PEOPLE HAS A CARRY PERMIT.
>> WE HAVE PROFESSIONALS, WE AS
A HOUSE BOMBS, WE HAVE PEOPLE
WHO ARE JUST EVERYDAY NORMAL
CITIZENS.
CRIMINALS PRAY AND LOOK FOR
VICTIMS AND THEY USUALLY LOOK
FOR THOSE WHO THEY BELIEVE ARE
DEFENSIVE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT WOMEN, WE
ARE TALKING ABOUT THE ELDERLY.
>> IT THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE
CRYING.
THERE'S ALWAYS GOING TO BE THE
DEVIL COMING TO KILL IN DETROIT
AND HE'S NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
PEOPLE WILL STILL OKAY.
I WOULD RATHER MY DAD ALWAYS
SAYS, I'D RATHER BE JUDGED BY 12
THAN CARRIED BY SIX, IS THAT HOW
IT GOES?
I MEAN, IT'S WHAT IT IS.
>> Tucker: HAS ALL GOES.
ALAYNA IS HARDLY ALONE.
PART TWO OF OUR SERIES ON BEING
MERELY ARMED IN A CITY OF
DETROIT APPEARS TOMORROW NIGHT.
GOOD LUCK TO BETO O'ROURKE TO
TAKE THOSE GUNS AWAY.
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON ACTUAL
SKILLS, PUBLIC SCHOOLS WANTS TO
TEACH KIDS THAT MATH IS RACIST.
THAT'S RIGHT.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO EDUCATION?